[Music]
hello hello
Doha how are you guys today it's so
great to be here with you guys I am so
inspired my last couple of days here
have been just absolutely amazing I've
met so many amazing people and it's an
honor to be here with you guys today in
the Y's summit now this theme unlearn
relearn what it means to be human
indeed this is the question of our age
everything is being called into question
so my name is Jason Silva many people
know me as the host of the
emmy-nominated television series brain
games on the National Geographic Channel
and the television show brain games
resonated across the world because it
taught people the ways in which our
brains perceive reality but also the
ways in which our brains miss perceive
reality and therefore you could say that
the show was very much about unlearning
and then relearning what it means to be
human now for me this all starts with a
passion for human imagination it starts
with a passion for human creativity and
this has turned into a passion for
technology and innovation for I believe
that technology is the embodiment of
human creativity in the world technology
is the literalization of human
imagination in the world technology is
how we turn the human mind inside out it
is how we exteriorize our minds in the
world concrete eyes in the form of tools
that we then use to extend and transform
our boundaries and redefine what it
means to be human and by the way this
has always been the case if you go back
a hundred thousand years the dawn of
humanity right in the savannas of
Africa when early humans first crawled
the land and they first picked up a
stick on the ground and they used that
stick to reach a fruit that was on a
really high tree branch we've been using
our sticks our rudimentary instruments
our tools to extend our reach to unlearn
and relearn what it means to be human to
redefine and to transcend our boundaries
as the philosopher Marshall McLuhan
famously said we build the tools and
bang the tools build us we have a
circular relationship right a self
amplifying feedback loop between us and
our tools that has snowballed and gotten
us to where we are today again crossing
a threshold unlearning and relearning
what it means to be human we didn't stay
in the caves as Ray Kurzweil said we
haven't stayed on the planet soon we
won't even stay within the limitations
of biology to be human is to be trans
human technology is our exoskeleton our
extended phenotype our second skin the
cognitive philosophers David Chalmers
and Andy Clarke in their famous essay
the extended mind thesis first put on
the following definition about the human
mind as it exists today that the mind is
not limited to the brain we exceed our
materials we have spilled out beyond our
brains and that the mind today is what
emerges in the feedback loops between
brains tools and environments right we
think with our tools we think through
our tools right we unlearn and we
relearn what it means to be human we
incorporate non-biological props and
scaffoldings into our cognitive
apparatus and continue to redefine what
we are now today we're living in the age
of rapid change right acceleration is
the new norm
disruption is the name of the game it
feels like the rug is being pulled from
underneath our feet there is a kind of
vertigo right there is apprehension and
fear right in the face of such massive
disruption where billion dollar
companies emerge from nowhere and
billion dollar established companies can
disappear just as quickly and the
question is why why does it feel like
reality is on time-lapse today right why
are we witnessing these changes in such
fast real-time because technology has
always changed the world it has always
disrupted the status quo it has always
forced us to contend to unlearn and to
relearn what it means to be human but
back in the day these technologies
changed over many generations right they
accrued over time so for most people you
were born and you died in a world that
didn't change very much right so it
wasn't as disruptive but technology
still emerged in a way to change the
world from the wheel to harnessing fire
for the first time that's a great
example all right there's a fabulous
book called how cooking made us human
that makes the case that when we first
harnessed fire for cooking
that was a prosthetic external stomach a
piece of technology that predigested our
food and made everything we ate more
absorbable more digestible and freed up
the cognitive real-estate for us to do
everything else before cooking we spent
most of our time
chewing so technology has always changed
the status quo harnessing electricity
the advent of the airplane right but
what makes today different now this has
to do with the rate at which technology
progresses right no doubt you guys have
heard of Gordon Moore the co-founder of
Intel now he was the first guy who
identified a very curious trend
about how technology progresses he
called it Moore's law and essentially
what he observed is that technology
progresses evolves at an exponential
rate but here's the thing human beings
evolved in a world that was linear and
local and so now living in a world that
is global and exponential creates a
cognitive dissonance because our
intuition continues to be linear
meanwhile technology progresses
exponentially so what is needed again is
to unlearn linearity and relearn to
think exponentially so that we can
properly address the grand challenges of
humanity using emerging exponential
technologies so what's a quick way of
understanding the implications the
difference between linear change and
exponential change perhaps no better
example exists than reycarts while
reycarts while wrote a book called the
singularity is near when humans
transcend biology and he is now the head
of engineering at Google and Bill Gates
called him the best guy alive at
predicting the future the example he
uses is called the 30 steps example so
if you take 30 linear steps you get to
30 right 30 steps of progress gets us to
30 right that's our intuition because a
hundred thousand years ago we had to
make a linear calculation to see how far
away that lion was and how quickly it
could get over and eat us our wiring is
linear but now take the same amount of
steps exponentially okay that's how
technology is progressing it's still 30
steps but each one is exponential so in
30 steps exponentially you get to a
billion think about it 30 linear steps
gets you to 30 30 exponential steps gets
you to a billion and technology is
advancing exponentially and that is the
reason why the smartphone in your pocket
today is a million times cheaper a
million times smaller and a thousand
times more powerful than what used to be
a 60 million dollar supercomputer that
was the size of this auditorium 40 years
ago now just consider the astonishing
progress that we've made look how far
we've come look how fast we've gotten
here in 40 years a supercomputer the
size of this building has shrunk down to
a device that fits in your pockets which
is a million times cheaper right that
means more people can afford it right a
million times smaller that means it fits
in your pocket and yet a thousand times
more powerful than that supercomputer
forty years ago that's why a young kid
in Doha today or in Mexico today when
the smartphone in their pocket has
better communications technology than a
president had 25 years ago how does this
change what becomes possible
we must unlearn and relearn what it
means to be human in the fact in the
face of the fact that the supercomputers
of yesterday when all of their potential
are now in the hands of everyone else
right we all have the tools to change
the world
and so we have to think differently
about what becomes possible Steven
Johnson wrote a magnificent best-selling
book called where good ideas come from a
natural history of innovation and in the
book he introduces the concept of the
adjacent possible now the adjacent
possible is like a shadow from the
future that hovers over the present and
provides a map of all the ways in which
the president can reinvent itself so
when I think about unlearning and
relearning what it means to be human I
think about the adjacent possible I
think about emerging technologies I
think about how to transform education
to harness the natural curiosity of
young minds and teach them about
exponential technologies to address the
grand challenges of humanity because
these exponential trends are not
stopping right in the next 25 years the
smartphone in your pocket will be a
blood cell size device in our bodies and
brains reverse engineering us from
inside out brain machine interfaces are
on their way what's also happening is
that software is
the world so biology is becoming a
programmable medium biology is becoming
an information technology so on the back
of advances and artificial intelligence
you also have exponential advances
happening in biotechnology and genetics
right because biotechnology means
mastering the information processes of
biology because it turns out that
biology is software DNA is code we are
made of language we are alphabetic all
the way down our genes are little
software programs and the speed at which
we are learning to harness and program
the software of biology is advancing
three times faster than exponential
think about that gene sequencing is
advancing three times faster than these
exponential rates it's why the eminent
physicist Freeman Dyson has written that
in the very near future a new generation
of artists are going to be writing
genomes with the fluency that Blake and
Byron wrote versus think about how
beautiful that is
when biology becomes the new canvas for
our artistry and our genius what must we
relearn right what must we unlearn in
order to harness the power of the
software of life to start self-modifying
ourselves and recursively self improve
ourselves and become something far
greater than what we are as shakespeare
famously said we know what we are we
know not what we might be so these are
the three exponentially emerging
technologies that in Silicon Valley they
say are leading us towards a
technological singularity or a Cambrian
explosion of mind it's artificial
intelligence right it's biotechnology
and it's also nanotechnology and with
nanotechnology we can pattern atoms and
program atoms which are the building
blocks of the physical world the same
way we program ones and zeroes with
digital technology so with
nanotechnology the world becomes a
programmable medium nanobots in our
bodies and brains buildings that self
assemble right technology as a resource
liberating mechanism as Peter Diamandis
wrote in abundance and scarcity as
something
that is contextual right everything must
be unlearned and relearned
even notions of scarcity itself on the
back of these three emerging
technologies right unlearn relearn so
how do we get kids excited about this
stuff how do we subvert the doom and
gloom or a media in which if it bleeds
it leads or the fear that the robots are
taking over our jobs we need to appeal
to the natural and innate human hunger
for knowledge I heard a neuroscientist
once described human beings not as
carnivores or omnivores
but as info vorse we need a constant
access to new interpretable information
right as isaiah berlin wrote to
understand is to perceive patterns as
Carl Sagan wrote understanding is a kind
of ecstasy right we need to appeal to
that insatiable curiosity that defines
the human spirit
we need to use aw as a portal to
knowledge right we must unlearn and
relearn by obliterating our mental
models of what is possible by
transcending what Michael Pollan calls
the bin bears and seen bats of the adult
mind and see the world as if through the
eyes of a child to awaken the minds
attention from the lethargy of custom
and the film of familiarity and
redirected towards the wonders of
existence research in Stanford and
Berkeley read recently on the subject of
awe right which they describe as an
experience of such perceptual expansion
that our mental models of what is
possible are obliterated to make room
for this new experience whether it's
learning something new for the first
time or witnessing a Qatar Airways
aircraft taking off into the sky or
gazing upon the stars in our solar
system and in our galaxy these
experiences stretch our minds and once a
mind is stretched by a new idea it never
returns to its original position and it
turns out that these experiences of awe
and wonder these transitory enchanted
moments even though they are temporary
they
leave us with a lasting afterglow with
cognitive benefits experiences of awe
leave us with increased feelings of
well-being increased feelings of
compassion increased feelings of
creativity right increased feelings of
connection with our fellow other
students and other people so we need to
use I believe all and wonder as the
entry points to open our minds to a
world beyond our imagination we must
unlearn
we must relearn what it means to be
human thank you very much thank you
thanks guys
thank you so much thank you thanks so
much Jason for for that fantastic speech
and that you've left us with a lot to
think about